n'y a pas qu'à mort pas qu'on sait
s'amuser ce week-end à saint cyr l'école
a eu lieu la traditionnelle fête foraine
de la ville pendant trois jours les
saint cyriens ont pu profiter en famille
les divers stands comme dopant autos
tamponneuses parano ou encore la pêche
aux canards une installation moins
conséquente cette année habituellement
installés sur la zone industrielle
renard les forains ont dû installer
leurs équipements sur le parking de la
gare est haute et on apporte quand même
un petit peu de joie autour de nous les
gens sont contents ça évite de penser à
leurs petits tracas quotidiens et de
pouvoir s'évader le temps de quelques
heures sur la fait tourner une petite
dizaine ont une petite dizaine mais
habituellement la fête de saint cyr ça
représentait une trentaine de manèges
quoi il ya de moins en moins d'espacé
rien et adaptée pour nous et ça c'est
regrettable
c'est une bonne idée maintenant je
comprends qu'il faut aussi de l'espace
ça pas toujours bonne réputation mais je
pense que dans les dans les villes un
petit peu comme ça c'est à l'école c'est
je pense que ça permet de proposer une
activité différente à la population
c'est pas longtemps qu'on est là mais
oui c'est divertissant donc c'est
intéressant